hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a really fun and challenging
geometry problem that's been spreading
around the internet
start out with this square with a side
length of 10.
on one side draw a semicircle and on an
adjacent side draw another semi-circle
now between the two corners of the
square draw a quarter circle
the challenge is to solve for this area
shaded in red
now just to present it in another way
let me label some of the intersection
points
abcd is a square with a side of 10
apd and cpd are semi circles and adq b
is a quarter circle
the problem is to solve for the shaded
area dpq
i think everyone who sent me this
problem it was a very popular suggestion
and in particular i thank chaitanya from
india who was the first person to send
me this problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
i admit it was very challenging
i originally solved it by making a
coordinate system and using calculus to
solve integrals
but i suspected this problem could be
solved using geometry and trigonometry
so i posted it to math stack exchange
within hours david k akilah hugh and
syed posted solutions and i thank them
for helping me understand how to solve
it using elementary methods
so in this video i'm going to present
three ways of solving the problem
i'll first go over the short way using
geometry and trigonometry then i'll
present a little bit of a longer way
and then finally i'll present the
calculus solution
so let's get started with the short way
in order to solve for this area we'll
solve it by finding the areas of two
shapes that will be easier to solve for
so we'll solve for this red area as the
area of this blue shape minus the area
of this yellow shape
so we have this
equation the blue and yellow shapes are
examples of a shape known as a geometric
lens that's the area when two circles
intersect
so since we need to know the area of a
geometric lens let's derive it generally
so we'll start out with a semi-circle
with a radius of a and perpendicular to
it we have a semi-circle with the radius
of b
we want to solve for this intersection
area
now to do that let's connect these two
radii to the intersection point and we
form a kite
now let's draw a line across this kite
so we're going to essentially solve for
this shape by solving for each of these
upper and lower shapes
so the area of intersection will be
equal to the area of this circular
sector
minus the area of this triangle and that
will give us the area of this lower half
of the lens
then we have this circular sector
minus this triangle and that will give
us the area of the upper half of the
lens
now the trick in this problem is that we
actually don't need to solve for the
areas of the triangles
we can actually solve for the total area
that they span
so to do that consider these two
triangles together
let's draw the other diagonal of this
kite
notice it divides the kite into two
right triangles
now each of these right triangles has
legs of a and b
so together to solve for the total area
of these triangles we need the areas of
two triangles who have one leg of a and
one leg of b
so each triangle has an area of one half
a b
so together both triangles will be equal
to a b
so now we need to solve for the areas of
these circular sectors and then subtract
a b and that'll be the area of this lens
so how can we solve for the areas of
each of these circular sectors
well we need to know the radius of each
circular sector that'll be easy it'll be
b for one circular sector and a for the
other and then we need to know the
central angle of each circular sector
so let's consider this right triangle
let's label this angle as theta
the other angle in this triangle will be
pi over 2 minus theta if we look at this
right triangle which is congruent to the
upper right triangle this will also be
theta
so here we have a central angle of two
theta corresponding to the radius of a
so we can solve for the area of this
circular sector
it'll be a squared over two times two
theta
in the other circular sector we have a
central angle that's equal to two times
the quantity pi over two minus theta so
it'll be equal to pi minus two theta so
we'll solve for the area of this
circular sector it'll be b squared over
two times the quantity pi minus two
theta
but what is theta
well we'll use trigonometry
in the right triangle theta will be
equal to the inverse tangent or the arc
tangent of b over a
so we can substitute that in for theta
and then we can simplify
and this will simplify to be the
quantity a squared minus b squared times
the inverse tangent of b over a plus pi
b squared all over two and then we need
to subtract from that a b
so this will be the area of a geometric
lens
so we now need to apply this formula to
the two lenses
in this blue shape we have a equal to 10
and b is equal to 5. so we substitute
those into the formula and then we
simplify to get 75 the inverse tangent
of 0.5 plus 12.5 pi minus 50.
in the yellow shape we have a and b
equal to 5.
so we substitute those in and then we
simplify
we now need to subtract the second
equation from the first
when we do that we can cancel out these
terms of 12.5 pi
and we get the answer of 75 the inverse
tangent of 0.5 minus 25 and that's
approximately 9.77
so that's one way to get the answer
but let's suppose you didn't realize you
needed to calculate the area of a
geometric lens how would you solve the
problem
well let's go over the longer geometric
way to solve it
it's essentially going to be the same
method but it'll be useful to go over
the steps to reinforce what we just went
over in the short method
so let's get started so let's solve for
the area of this yellow shape
to do that let's get rid of some
irrelevant shapes
we'll draw a line down the middle
dividing it into two equal circular
segments
so we just need to solve for the area of
one circular segment and then multiply
by two
now to do the area of one of these
circular segments we'll draw in this
isosceles right triangle
so this circular segment will be equal
to this quarter circle minus the area of
this triangle
as the radius of this semi-circle is 5
the area of this quarter circle is pi
times 5 squared over 4 and the area of
this triangle is 5 times 5 over two
so the area of this circular segment is
equal to 25 pi over four minus 25 over
two
the area of this yellow shape will equal
two times this which will equal 12.5 pi
minus 25
and this is the same result as we had
before in the short method
so we now need to solve for the area of
this blue shape
how can we do that
we'll draw a line at the two
intersection points
and we'll solve for each of these areas
this upper area and this lower area and
we want the sum of these two areas but
we'll solve for them individually
so this upper area how do we solve for
it
well we'll draw in our kite-like figure
as before
and we'll draw in the values of these
distances
we'll also draw the diagonal of this
kite
so notice this kite now has
two right triangles who have legs of 5
and 10.
let's label this angle as theta
now
we want the area of this upper circular
segment and it'll be equal to the area
of this circular sector minus the area
of this triangle
we'll put in the dimensions of each of
these shapes
the area of a circular sector is equal
to one half times ten squared times two
theta and the area of this triangle will
equal one half times ten squared times
the sine of two theta
now theta in this case is equal to the
inverse tangent of 5 over 10 or 0.5
we can also solve
for the sine of 2 times theta by the
double angle identity sine of 2 theta is
equal to 2 times the sine of theta times
the cosine of theta
we can get these sine and the cosine by
solving for the hypotenuse and then
solving for the sine and cosine of each
of these angles and this all simplifies
to be four over five
so we substitute these values in to our
formula above
and we get the area of this blue shape
is equal to the following which we can
simplify to be 100 times the inverse
tangent of 0.5 minus 40.
now to solve for this lower part of the
area we do a very similar calculation
we put in our kite
and then we need to solve for the area
of this circular sector minus the area
of this triangle
now the key in this we have the
dimension which is a radius of 5 but we
need to know this angle
now since one angle is equal to theta in
a right triangle the other angle will
equal pi over 2 minus theta
and this angle will also equal pi over 2
minus theta
so the central angle will equal pi minus
2 theta
so the area of the circular sector is
equal to phi squared over 2 times the
central angle and the area of this
triangle is phi squared over two times
the sine of this central angle
so how can we simplify this
we can simplify sine of pi minus two
theta because sine of pi minus two theta
is equal to sine of 2 theta
and we already figured out sine of 2
theta in the previous calculation is
equal to 4 5
so we substitute these values in and
then simplify to get that this is equal
to 12.5 pi minus 25 the inverse tangent
of 0.5
minus 10.
so we now can solve for the area of this
blue shape by substituting in the values
we just derived
we then simplify it to be 75 times the
inverse tangent of 0.5 minus 50 plus
12.5 pi
so now we get the area of this blue
shape
and we need to substitute that in and
substitute in the area of this yellow
shape
we then subtract the yellow shape from
the blue shape so these 12.5 pies cancel
out and it all simplifies to be 75 times
the inverse tangent of 0.5 minus 25 and
that's approximately 9.77 just as before
so you can see if we didn't see the
trick about the triangles it's a little
bit longer but it can be solved if you
work through it
now let's suppose that you couldn't
figure out the geometric way
you may have approached it like i did
using calculus so first we'll put in a
coordinate system
here is the y-axis and here is the
x-axis
we'll now label some points in this
diagram
now all of these are quarter circles or
semicircles so this curve will equal
the square root of the quantity 25 minus
x squared this upper curve will equal
the square root of 100 minus x squared
minus 5
and this semicircle will equal 5 minus
the square root of the quantity 25 minus
the quantity x minus 5 squared
so we have three different curves that
are bounding this area
now we can solve for the final
intersection point by equating the two
equations
this point will be eight comma one
so now we can solve for the area of this
shape as follows
we need the area of the upper curve
going between zero and eight and then we
subtract the area of the lower curve
going from zero to five and then we
subtract the area of the other lower
curve going from five to eight so we
want the integrals of each of these as
follows
so now we need to simplify these
integrals
well this middle integral will be easy
to simplify because it's the area of a
quarter circle with a radius of 5. so we
don't actually need to do the integral
we know that this will be equal to 5
squared times pi over 4 which is 25 pi
over 4.
so that's one part solved
now this next integral will split into
two integrals
with the integral from 0 to 8 of the
square root minus the integral from 0 to
8 of the constant 5.
the second integral is easy to evaluate
it'll be equal to 40.
so now how do we solve for this first
integral
we'll use a trigonometric substitution x
is equal to 10 sine theta
this means dx is equal to 10 cosine of
theta d theta
we also need to change the limits of
integration from going between 0 to the
inverse sine of 0.8
so we substitute that in
then we need to simplify that 100 minus
100 sine squared of theta is equal to
100 cosine squared of theta
we then simplify this all out
now we can solve for this because the
integral of cosine squared of theta is
very well known
so we substitute that in and we evaluate
from the limits of integration
and it simplifies to be 50 times the
inverse sine of 0.8 plus 24 and we
subtract 40.
so this will be 50 times the inverse
sine of 0.8 minus 16.
so that'll be the first integral
we now need to do a similar thing for
this very last integral
we split it up into two different
integrals this first integral will be
equal to 15.
this next integral we can solve first by
doing a u substitution let's say u is
equal to x minus five so we change the
limits of integration and we now get the
integrand is the square root of 25 minus
u squared
to solve for this integral we can do a
trigonometric substitution that u is
equal to 5 sine of theta
it'll be a very similar calculation to
the first integral that we figured out
and i'm just going to skip some of the
steps it all comes down to be negative 6
minus 12.5 the inverse sine of 0.6
so we put this all together and we get
that this simplifies to be 9 minus 12.5
times the inverse sine of 0.6
so we now just need to simplify this
expression
and that's our answer we have 50 times
the inverse sine of 0.8 plus 12.5 times
the inverse sine of 0.6 minus 25 minus
25 pi over 4. but this is quite a bit
more complicated than the geometry and
trigonometric solution and i wondered
how could we reconcile it how can we get
it to be
using the inverse tangent and just you
know two simple terms
so let's try and reconcile these two
answers
well we can do that by drawing this
right triangle this 345 right triangle
notice that theta is equal to the
inverse sine of 0.6 and alpha is equal
to the inverse sine of 0.8
furthermore theta plus alpha is equal to
pi over 2 because these two angles sum
to be 90 degrees
therefore 12.5 times the inverse sine of
0.8 plus 12.5 times the inverse sine of
0.6 must be equal to 12.5 times pi over
2.
so how can that help us
well
what we're going to do is this first
term where we have 50 times the inverse
sine of 0.8 we're going to split it up
into 37.5 times the inverse sine of 0.8
and 12.5 times the inverse sine of 0.8
so now we have 12.5 times the inverse
sine of 0.8 plus 12.5 times the inverse
sine of 0.6 and this is equal to 25 pi
over 4.
so we substitute that in and it cancels
out with this other 25 pi over four
so this all simplifies to be 37.5 times
the inverse sine of 0.8 minus 25 and
this is approximately equal to 9.77 so
it's equivalent to our answer it's just
two terms
but something still bothered me about it
because it's the inverse sine and the
previous answer was equal to the inverse
tangent
so how can we reconcile those two
components
well i looked up this formula
if you substitute in x is equal to 0.8
you get that this simplifies to be 2
times the inverse tangent of 0.5
and that gives us our final equivalence
that this is equal to 75 times the
inverse tangent of 0.5 minus 25
so we verified our solution using
calculus
did you figure out this problem and
which method did you use
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over a hundred
million views please subscribe for free
to get the newest videos and email me a
puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise on teespring you can check
out my books which are listed in the
video description and you can support me
on patreon for exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support